former hedge fund manager and
pharmaceutical CEO Martin shkreli faces
up to 20 years in prison for his
conviction here in New York in federal
court on security fraud and conspiracy
Crowley gained notoriety for raising the
price of a life-saving drug 5,000% and
for the most part thumbing his nose at
prosecutors during his five week trial
tonita copal is here with the details
Tony good morning good morning
shkreli became the poster boy for greed
on Wall Street after he drastically
raised the price of a drug purchased by
his former company but that's actually
not what got him in trouble with the law
Martin shkreli whose critics cast him as
a wolf of Wall Street walked out of
federal court and stood sheepishly as
his lawyer tried to spin his conviction
for security fraud and conspiracy five
out of eight counts not guilty
is in our view a very good verdict
prosecutors allege shkreli misled
investors about the finances of his
hedge fund msnb capital and accused him
of starting a second hedge fund and a
health care company in order to pay them
back if this was a witch-hunt of epic
proportions and maybe they found one or
two broomsticks
but at the end of the day we've been
acquitted of the most important charges
in this case and I'm delighted to report
that for years shkreli has repeatedly
found himself battling in the court of
public opinion most famously back in
2015 when as CEO of turing
pharmaceuticals he raised the price of a
drug that treats parasitic infections
from $13.50 to $750 per pill on the
advice of counsel I invoke my Fifth
Amendment privilege
shkreli seemed amused at times when he
appeared before a congressional
committee investigating the issue are
you listening yes but he defended the
5,000 percent increase which earned him
the nickname farmer bro online in an
interview with CBS News there's a
company that was selling an Aston Martin
at the price of a bicycle and we buy
that company and we check we ask to
charge total prices I don't think that
should be a crime it wasn't a crime but
just three months later FBI agents
arrested shkreli on a matter
to his hedge funds after his conviction
on Friday skellies lawyer Benjamin
Bronfman did acknowledge his client has
a PR problem Martin is a brilliant young
man but sometimes people skills don't
translate well so we will have some good
discussions
shkreli said before the trial I'm so
innocent the jury judge and the
prosecution are going to give me an
apology well he now faces up to 20 years
in prison and the judge is taking some
further action he has to schedule a
sentencing date I didn't I didn't mean
to have an outburst there but no look
everything I know it's like and I don't
know if you I don't know if you're being
accused of being a witch that you
acknowledge that there are brooms there
that's probably not the best way to go
about it but as the lawyer said there
are some people skills problems tell me
the köppen thanks very much